uh right uh good morning afternoon
everyone thanks so much for uh being out
here
I'm obviously very happy with the
outcome of the case and it looks like
I'm not having to retire from my day job
after all but at the same time I'm
unbelievably frustrated that basis
claims like this are allowed to go to
court at all we've spent the last eight
years talking about two songs with
dramatically Different lyrics Melodies
and four chords which are also different
and used by songwriters every day all
over the world these chords are common
building blocks which were used to
create music long before Let's Get It On
was written and will be used to make
music long after we are all gone they
are in a Songwriter's alphabet our
toolkit and should be there for all of
us to use no one owns them all the all
the way they are played in the same way
that nobody owns the color blue